there wasn't much time to pack before
france's ambassador to australia boarded
a plane to paris ordered out of his
embassy by a president furious at being
cut out of an international deal before
departing he had spoken of his sadness
at how things developed
i would like to be able to run into a
time machine
and you know to win it back
and be the situation where
where we don't end up in such uh
an incredible
clumsy
inadequate
and australian situation
the u.s ambassador also told to head for
the elysee where he'll meet a president
whose mood has hardened emmanuel macron
incensed that canberra washington and
london came to an agreement to help
australia develop nuclear submarines
denying france a multi-billion pound
order for conventional vessels
america and france were still talking
today at a g7 meeting in the north of
england but the president of the french
national assembly and a man close to
macron told sky news trust has been
damaged
i think this is somewhat tarnished the
bonds of friendship that we have yes it
has made things more difficult in terms
of trust and friendship
language more restrained than that of
the french foreign minister who called
the agreement a brutal decision which
reminded him of donald trump's tactics
and seasoned french diplomats say
macron's hardline move is justified it's
unprecedented but it's a serious
situation because we feel that we are
betrayed it has been down behind our
backs the contract was important because
it implied jobs in in france and it was
a 56
million euros contract and
which has been
done
years ago so
this is really
something which is unacceptable
president macron is furious he only
learned of the australian america and uk
deal by letter hours before it was
announced and yet many question why
given three nations are involved in the
agreement the french ambassador to the
uk hasn't been recalled the french are
are particularly upset with the united
states rather than the uk because it's
american subs that are replacing the
french subs but also because i think
they feel it it was the responsibility
of washington
to
uh approach this issue in a more
transparent fashion president macron has
taken a hard diplomatic stance his fury
over the loss of the deal likely made
worse given he's going into a french
election next year
international relations are destined for
a rocky period michelle clifford sky
news brussels